no habrás tradición inmediata a Estados
Unidos para Ovidio Guzmán El hijo del
narcotraficante Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán
un juez Federal concedió la suspensión
de oficio respecto a la extradición y su
ejecución se decreta de plano la
suspensión de oficios Respecto a los
actos consistentes en la deportación
expulsión extradición y ejecución para
el efecto de que no se ejecuten y el
quejoso quede en lugar en el que se
encuentre a disposición de este juzgado
solo en relación a su libertad personal
y no sea entregado al gobierno de los
Estados Unidos de América ni a ningún
estado diverso el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador también
señaló que las tradiciones EEUU de alias
El ratón líder de los chapitos no será
Fast Track o rápida Pese a que el
departamento de Justicia estadounidense
lo reclama desde 2019 su captura el
jueves en Culiacán desató una ola de
violencia por parte del Cartel De
Sinaloa los narcos sembraron el terror
en la capital de Sinaloa con cortes de
vías secuestros de vehículos
afectaciones infraestructuras y decenas
de vuelos cancelados los enfrentamientos
con las fuerzas de seguridad dejan un
saldo de al menos 29 muertos más de 30
heridos y 21 detenidos 35 militares se
encuentran lesionados por arma de fuego
a quien se les está brindando la
atención médica en instalaciones
hospitalarias tanto civiles como
militares
Asimismo hasta el momento no se tiene
información de ningún civil inocente que
haya perdido la vida resultado de estas
operaciones
hace tres años y tres meses Culiacán
vivió escenas similares cuando El hijo
menor del Chapo Fue capturado por
primera vez posteriormente fue liberado
por orden de amlo para evitar ataques a
civiles ahora Ovidio Guzmán se encuentra
en Ciudad de México pero cerca de 4.500
efectivos permanecen desplegados en
Sinaloa y Estados cercanos